[Music]
[Applause]
uh Dan Wetzel Yahoo sports National
columnist since 2003 New York Times
best-selling author joins us on the
program you've been writing about the
situation at Northwestern what issues do
you have with this story
ah
the biggest if you want to call it an
issue is we just don't really know the
the full scope of what happened
uh Northwestern did this seven month
investigation you know they get they get
the Whistleblower complaint last
November they hire an outside Law Firm
they spend you know about seven months
on this interview 50 plus people go
through all the texts emails they're
doing player surveys Through The Years
um sounds very comprehensive uh for what
was going on in the culture of the
locker room and then as a private
institution they don't have to release
this document this investigation the way
you would if you were a public school
and this was a public document so they
release an executive summary that has
zero details into what actually happened
and uh let alone kind of the context and
the perspectives and things like that
and
uh so you know no one really knows what
the situation was they suspend
um the president suspends Pat Fitzgerald
on Friday says okay I've read he's
obviously read this whole thing and says
two-week suspension
um I thought that was very naive not to
release this the whole thing for
everyone to see and get out in front of
the story and then the story comes out
in the student newspaper and on ESPN
that the the original complaintant is
telling his his uh side of the story
which
could be 100 accurate and all of that
but we don't have any of the other
perspective of the other 50 plus people
that shaped the original decision and
once the the details of the complaintant
come out all sudden three days later Pat
Fitzgerald's fired and so
um I think the rest of us are left to
say I don't truly know we can assume the
worst we can assume this or that we
don't really know what happened and why
on Friday was it good enough for West
for I'm sorry for Northwestern to say
um you're suspended for two weeks and
then on Monday you're five you know
you're fired you're done get out of here
uh that's a dramatic switch in three
days when no real new information had
come out and that's where I started to
go okay let me look at the Timeline here
usually Friday news dump uh here we are
in July and it almost felt like hey can
we sneak this one by the goalie here and
uh he's been suspended for two weeks it
felt like once we knew he was suspended
for two weeks then our curiosity was
well wait a minute
what gets you suspended for two weeks in
July and not maybe a couple of games or
how serious is this because nothing
changed from Friday to Monday except for
Pat Fitzgerald got fired
well yeah that and and some of the
details started coming out that's why I
think Northwestern I'm not here to say
Pat Fitzgerald should should or should
not have his job or they acted in the
wrong maybe they should have fired him
on Friday and they made a mistake that
and they corrected on Monday I don't
know oh I'm just looking at it from afar
we don't know all the details there is a
big report there is a thorough
investigation yeah and they sat there
and said okay let's give them two weeks
off in the middle of summer where
nothing is happening at Northwestern
um if you're going to suspend someone
for two weeks these are the two weeks to
do it that literally no impact on
anything there's barely any recruiting
going on uh you know go to your lake
house come back in two weeks we're gonna
implement this stuff we will we will
root out the culture that's a problem so
they were all in agreement on Friday and
then the details come out what they
should have done uh right or wrong
whatever if it led to this or not is
released the entire report allow all of
the context and perspective to come out
I'm not saying any again the
complaintant could be 100 accurate and
what is described is
um is troubling and ridiculous and all
those things but many times with the
stuff you want the full perspective this
was a court this is a this is a court
case it's not a criminal court case it's
not a civil court case but it's in the
court of public opinion why are we
keeping our coach why are we firing our
coach what you don't do if you're the
school or a defense attorney is ever
just let the witness uh the complaint
and get up and tell his story and then
say we have no questions we have no
opening statement we have no uh rebuttal
we have no Witnesses nothing we're just
going to sit here uh and that's what
Northwestern kind of seeded the the the
narrative in the court of public opinion
and then when it started to shift
perhaps rightfully yeah
um they can't they all sudden change
their mind and go to the Jurassic step
of firing so I thought the whole I don't
know that the result is wrong I just
know this the the way they got to it is
is Highly Questionable and was botched
and so maybe again they should have
fired him on Friday why did the
president not fire him on Friday and
then on Mondays to say oh my I'm just so
troubled by this he this guy has to go
instead of saying look he you know what
whatever justification they came up with
on for I assume it's he's been here 17
years he he you know we can we can stop
we can stop hazing very quickly this
isn't something that's like impossible
to stop we can you know you can stop it
right away it'll never happen on the
2023 team uh instead it's just like he's
got to go so really awkward clumsy
effort uh on how they got to this maybe
it's the right decision maybe it's the
wrong one I just neither I nor pretty
much any one other the president
Northwestern has any idea about the full
context of the story yeah and the cynic
in me if he's 11-1 last year not one and
eleven uh he's not as vulnerable it
feels like also did coaches know about
this assistant coaches the new head
coach the interim head coach players
seniors June you know Juniors were they
culpable in this uh you know is there
sexual assault that's in here uh did
they violate northwestern's code of
conduct I mean there's a lot to unravel
here other than it felt like hey two
weeks
let's move on uh fire the coach let's
move on it just feels like this is a
ball of yarn uh Dan that is just going
to keep on unraveling here and might get
even uglier
until you release the full report
it's going to keep dripping out that was
an extremely naive by Northwestern to
assume to just say hey guys it and look
when you when you suspend Someone Like
Pat Fitzgerald on a Friday in the summer
on the week of July 4th
it's a news dump to try to hide the
story right yeah it's such an obvious
news dump that it becomes the story it
becomes obvious nobody is getting fooled
like wait Pat Fitzgerald is getting
suspended what is going on here oh we
just we just finished don't worry uh
just calm down let everyone enjoy their
weekend cook some hamburgers and we'll
be fine no everyone's gonna go wait a
minute and and the naivete of thinking
the complainant
who is not bound by any confidentiality
is going to just sit there and say okay
I'm good with this I definitely will not
talk to the media about what I I so this
this complaint and saying I didn't get
what I wanted out of this so I'm going
to ramp it up and I'm going to tell the
my my story was not told in this
executive summary it just said there was
some things and uh you know we'll just
move on he's saying heck heck no I'm
gonna tell my story and good for him is
that right what he went through the
story he told and what he went through
he deserves to to tell his story so he
goes out and tells it and now all right
we gotta go yeah and then you sit there
and say well they won four games in two
years but then on the other side they're
trying to raise money for a new 800
million dollar football stadium and Pat
Fitzgerald is extremely popular and
connected with so how much did all of
these things did that play in on Friday
we can't fire this guy we we got to
build the stadium
um or was it now well he wasn't winning
anyway
nobody knows anything and everyone's now
curious America loves a mystery and
Northwestern created a mystery on
something that perhaps was a simple
solution or perhaps not but eventually
this store this report has to come out
because perhaps there is context perhaps
there is other Witnesses perhaps it gets
worse I don't know I don't know what's
in the report maybe it looks even worse
and you go how the heck did you not fire
him on Friday or maybe you read it and
go yeah maybe you give the guy another
chance
Northwestern trying to hide by this has
done no good on a story that it I I
agree is a yarn a ball of yarn that's
going to keep going good to talk to you
as always Dan thank you for joining us
thanks Dan talk to you soon that's Dan
Wetzel Yahoo sports National columnist
and New York Times best-selling author